do you think religion is necessary yes
[Music]
i'm not even religious yes we live in a
christian society
that's true and we we mentioned this the
other day i think i mentioned it to alan
west that
people like bill maher he doesn't
realize that his values are actually
rooted in judeo-christian values
correct and he thinks he's a secular
atheist and he his morals aren't defined
by the bible and it's like bro
they are they are they literally are you
don't understand
that the fifth amendment in the fifth
amendment the right to a trial by jury a
speedy trial the right to remain silent
all that stuff
that comes partly from blackstone's
formulation when he said it is better
that ten guilty persons escaped than one
innocent person suffer
benjamin franklin said it's better that
a hundred guilty persons escaped than
one innocent person suffer
that came from the story of sodom and
gomorrah that god said for if there is
but one righteous person i will not
destroy this city
these ideas have existed for a very very
long time there are certain cultures
that don't
share that notion take a look at china's
history and their religion
they're an authoritarian communist sort
of communist nation
they don't have the same ideas about
innocent until proven guilty
you can take a look at some i am not
saying that every country that has ever
practiced this religion has
held these values certainly there have
been authoritarian nations that have
been
christian i'm saying that when we look
to these values
they have a root in judeo-christian
values 100 percent
there was
they had a whole entire moral and legal
framework
for their entire civilization that's got
nothing to do with what we got going on
yeah nothing so bill maher sitting there
in his jacuzzi with his hookers and his
cocaine and his weed as he admits
thinks that he's an atheist who just
came up with these ideas of these values
that somehow they're universal they're
not universal first of all
entire civilizations have lived and
flourished and failed
eventually without these values and
without this uh the these
norms and here we are this is the most
successful culture
in the world ever based on christianity
here's for a new religion here's what
well we have it it's called critical
race there it's called
a theory a good one sure here's what
here's what
you know bill maher thinks he looks to
backwards and confused
and poorly translated versions of
religion and then says see it's a bad
thing
and i use bill maher as an example
because i was just complimenting the guy
right
there are a lot of people who look to
religion and say here are all these bad
things and it's like okay well
what about all the good things i'm not a
religious person i i am not
theistic in any sense of you know these
religious texts or anything
anything like that anything like that
but i certainly think
you can find good ideas in every single
religious text okay obviously
every single i'm just being you know
hyperbolic but for the most part you'll
look at these religions
and you will find there's probably
something good in them
maybe not enough maybe it's 51 bad 49
good okay well then take the good stuff
and get rid of the bad stuff
that's what we've done here in the
united states there was a lot of really
bad stuff
well we started to get rid of all that
bad stuff and keep all the good stuff
that turns into sections of the bill of
rights
first of all the first amendment the
right to practice your religion and then
you have
the right to you know trial by jury
innocent until proven guilty
and that is rooted that's just a fact
it's rooted in
judeo-christian values in the story of
sodom and gomorrah i was like reading
about this and i was actually
really just impressed when i read about
i started researching blackstone's
formulation why did he come up with the
idea and the history of it that's right
religion so it's not absolute i don't
think you need it
but that's why i'm saying when you asked
if religion was necessary i kind of went
i don't know about religion we're
finding out right now
but you don't need religion you need
shared a shared moral framework
and what many what many that that's what
it is
no a religion is like i i have faith in
the lord
or a lot of them is a cult like i have
faith in this guy that was telling me
about the lord
right you need a shared moral framework
okay religion is is
okay where does your moral framework
come from in the united states our moral
framework is judeo-christian taoism
not every single nation that has been
successful has a judeo-christian moral
framework but they do
share a moral framework some moral
frameworks are really really
awful and they're really nasty based on
our standards
but that's the point i'm saying bill
maher's moral framework is rooted in an
american
judeo-christian moral framework this is
this country is not in my opinion
founded to be expressly a christian
nation but it was
overwhelmingly christian people who
created it
it's christian in its form and function
yes but not what i mean is there's no
state religion
there's not right they avoided making a
state religion by
baking the religion into the structure
of the government
well i i think what you're basically
saying is they took the moral framework
of the religion and
and structured it into government but it
left out a lot of the things they didn't
like
yeah they're like hey you can be here
and not be christian but by the way all
of our laws our rules our regulations
our morals the structure
how you're gonna live your life it's
christian are the evolution
of a judeo-christian moral framework now
you have secular individuals who don't
believe in god and don't believe in the
bible
and don't realize their moral framework
is rooted in an american culture that
was very religious
and look man look tim i want to go back
to what you're saying before
we don't have we want to go to mars
let's give us meaning oh we need a we
need the cold war we need meaning
what you're looking for is something
bigger than yourself
that's right a mission not just a
mission because missions
end where do you think god came from
aside from actually being the creator of
the universe if that's what you believe
it is the need for a persistent
source of meaning outside of yourself
that will not be seasonal that does not
go away
once the cold war is over does not go
away once we integrate with the aliens
that does not go away when manifest
destiny is completed
you need a consistent and eternal sense
of meaning that is
outside of yourself so you don't get
lost in your own brain and turn into a
freaking victim
and sit around and say where's my stuff
i don't think missions have to end
like missionaries that's their life is
the mission and
the the pro the uh enterprise the uss
enterprise
that was it the naval ship persistent
mission
but it could come to an end it could but
it's not supposed to
because the infinite infinite universe
created by god that they're exploring
yes oh bro they're not spoiling the
universe they're exploring a one
quadrant of the galaxy
thank you for uh i walked into the tim
compound today and what's playing
star trek next generation hold on hold
on a minute
the episode that was playing the hour
before was the
there are four lights tim i want to make
it there four lights straight but i
don't know in response to
all this nonsense right now that you've
been spewing i'm four lighting it right
now
four lights you're the guy that would
say that four lights for those that
don't know this winston
listen listen let's talk about shared
shared culture
when i was a little kid i remember
sitting on my couch my dad was watching
star trek star trek the next generation
i understood very little of it there's a
reason why i love that show
and it's because of the philosophy and
the storytelling
and let me explain to all of you who
don't understand the holodeck let me
explain to all of you who don't
understand what it means when you say
there are four lights
captain jean-luc picard was captured
by enemies and he was being tortured
mercilessly
and the man torturing him had four
lights above him
and he asked captain picard how many
lights are there and picard said
there are four and then he presses a
button activating a torture device and
says you're mistaken
there are five lights and no matter how
hard he tried to
force captain picard to say something
that was not true
picard would not do it i know a lot of
people are like star trek's a silly
thing it's a sci-fi show no
you know what i learned growing up
seeing stories like that
there will never be a moment in my life
where you come to me and tell me to say
something that is not true
and i will say it i will look you in the
eyes and say there are four lights
when you come to me with your stupid
fake news garbage
and you say we will ban you we will
destroy you we will take your income we
will take your life
say there are five lights or else i'll
look you in the eyes and say
there are four lights that's what star
trek's about it seems like that show was
brilliant
and that was a show made by americans in
the 90s actually 1989
and that was the value being instilled
in people at that time and i grew up
with shows like that
today they have dogmatic cult-like
garbage
they are instilling into people and they
are ruining the classically liberal
defiant individualistic content that
taught us to be good people
to respect one another now they're
telling us the opposite
now colleges are segregating people
based on race when star trek was the
show
that they say had the first interracial
kiss apparently that may be a myth
but it did and it was important and
there was this really famous story i
read
about the woman who played captain uhura
on on star trek
when she was speaking with dr king i
don't know if the story is true i read
it somewhere
and maybe it was dr king maybe i'm doing
the story way wrong and she didn't want
to be on the show and he said you are
fourth in command to a federation
starship you do not quit that show
think about the message being sent to
little kids about what you represent
amazing that was star trek where are we
today
it's almost as if we've been occupied by
a virus that seeks our own destruction
the borg a hundred percent were our
nation's infected with a virus that
seeks to kill the host the struggle
session
this whole thing this is this this is a
struggle session
was going through a struggle session
this feels like a struggle yeah since
this is
jumping at the end of the episode at the
end of the episode picard was asked was
told
by the guy torturing him he said you can
choose to live
in pain and suffering or you can be
comfortable
comfortable clothes and all the women
your at your heart's content
and he says what must i do and he say
tell me how many lights there are
and picard is looking and that's when
the other guards come in
to release picard and give him back to
the federation at the end of the episode
he's talking to the counselor and he
says
i would have said anything and i
actually believed
there were five lights yeah nobody's
perfect because torture does that to you
but but it's it's amazing i wonder what
inspired these writers when they write
these brilliant things well that's 1984
dude that's like a scene right out of
1980 right absolutely
i think about shows like you know
futurama
have you ever seen jurassic park that's
what it was called and it was the it was
an episode about
you know fry and his dog gets fossilized
and he decides
whether or not he's gonna bring his dog
back or there was also the episode about
fry's brother who kept stealing his his
ideas and his moves
talk about amazing writing an amazing
show the character fry
talks about how he's a seven-leaf clover
and it gave him all the luck in the
world
but his brother yanzi kept stealing
everything from him he then learns
because it's a
feature arms about a guy who travels a
thousand years in the future that a guy
named philip j
fry who looks just like his brother was
taking all his dreams going to mars
being in a rock band and he had a seven
leaf clove clover at the end of the
episode when he goes to rob
the grave of what he thinks is his
brother who stole everything
he learns that it was actually his
nephew that his brother
named after him because his brother
loved him what happened to shows like
that
this amazing writing where you're
watching this dumb comedy show
and you end up crying afterwards with
that episode and the episode jurassic
park
what happened to shows like star trek
even deep space nine was also amazing
profound writing now we have
transformers godzilla versus you know
king kong i get it we probably had
movies like this in the past
yeah but i'm saying it's cultural decay
i mean even scrubs would get you
serious riley dude wait wait no
again they'd be getting like sorry big
difference
riley's also good it's flooded the
industry's flooded so they have to like
do these beacons of light in the sense
of like let's do a reboot that
everyone's going to put their eyes on
in 1989 it was like five 12 channels you
know
one production company that or like you
know segment of production companies
that could pick what got seen
i love marvel movies but there is not a
single marvel movie
and probably i don't know maybe i'm
wrong but on top of my head i don't
think i can name a movie in the past
five years
that gives me the same sense of like awe
and emotion that i get from like
i think the episode of star trek was
called the make of a man when data the
andrew was on trial and they're trying
to determine whether or not he was a
sentient living being with full rights
and they talk about what makes a person
a person amazing this is amazing
roddenberry was was he still
his wife also was or she was in the show
uh roddenberry was he still involved
with the writing of
the next generation i'm pretty sure next
generation was high quality i remember
watching it but i watched i watched all
of that
what what are we leaving for our kids
right so that so i'm gonna throw to the
grammys now
and actually say to candice owens she's
right
i look at that story about star trek and
captain uhura a black woman who was
fourth in command to into it to
the flagship of the of the federation
and it's a piece of fiction and it's
it's silly and everything but think
about what that means as a culture of
what we're telling our kids
that you can be the best of the best the
top highest ranking or one of them
now it's cardi b on a giant bed
jumping up and down on a song called
whap we're getting trouble on youtube
we've even tell you the name of it i
can't
even that's that that's that's that's
the culture today explain how
how demoralized i am with that with that
grammy performance with the whole cardi
b phenomenon with this
i can't i can't so did you just say that
youtube is more conservative
definitely than the legacy media yeah
absolutely look i don't care if cardi b
wants to do those dances okay that's
fascinating assessment
i mean i agree with you but it's just
it's fascinating to think that
culturally
they will censor whatever wap means
and yet you blasted out over the
airwaves
on on the grammys now listen i am not
offended at all in any way by the wet
performance
i really don't care in the sense that if
you want to have your own show and you
want to do that
by all means go and do it i'm just not
going to watch it much like the lgbtq
captain america
i'm glad you guys get your presentation
i think it's important
i'm happy you guys have a comment you're
enjoying me personally
i'm not gonna buy it i don't like mint
ice cream i don't like chocolate chip
mint i think mint is gross
i don't want to take it away from
anybody else i'm not offended by it i
just won't buy it
so the grammys can do their show and i'm
not going to watch it
but my criticism is that what do we then
share
as a mass culture where we all actually
say this is something that inspires us
and it makes us feel better oh yeah
that's gone
social cohesion is gone the top-down
one-to-many model of communication and
social cohesion
gone forever the only thing at this
point now that's going to bring
total cohesion is a return
my boy michael millerman knows what i
mean when i say it or return what does
that mean
return not everything old is bad
and not everything new is good and and
it's true yeah i think it's funny i was
taking these political tests you know
like the eight values and like the
political compass
my political compass test man i am
further left and further libertarian
than i've ever been
reading like through these tests but you
know what i realized the political
compass test is outdated
it doesn't ask anything about the modern
culture war the modern left or right
it asks you like how do you feel about
progressive taxes and like multinational
corporations so i'm like that doesn't
matter
but i was taking these tests and i was
just looking at some of these questions
and it's it's it's very interpretable
i guess what i'm trying to say is when
we try to understand someone's politics
you could ask someone a question like do
you think
major corporations have an advantage in
their ability to move quickly
and execute plans quickly no i i didn't
ask you if you thought it was good or
bad
oh i just think the answer to that
question is no do you don't think
corporations have an advantage over
moving quickly absolutely not that's the
biggest downfall over the government
oh over the government yes they can move
more quickly than the government i'm not
saying you like it and
that's what happens people end up
looking at you know these political
compass tests and political tests and
it's like no the only question dividing
us politically and will be eventually we
will all be sorted by this 100 percent
is do you believe
in essentialism or do you believe in the
blank slate that's going to be the final
dividing line
divine define those things essentialism
that we are
and act who we are based on our biology
our hormones our size our strength
that you can't disconnect biology from
the way you behave and culture etc and
blank slate is that you're born with
nothing constructivism and you are
injected
with all the things that you believe and
all of your interests and all of your
desires and all of your capabilities and
all of your aptitudes
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you